Thank you very much, I'm really
delighted to be here sharing with
all this great community with
everyone, so what a pleasure and let
's start with this experience that I've
had working and playing a little with a
bike, so let me tell you and let's
start with this  moment so
first of all who am I good at
today oscar barajas better known as
gnx on social networks and well there is a
passion for teaching a
passion for technology and
particularly for javascript even though
other programming languages ​​call my attention
and today  Today
I am working with the entire ecosystem
that has to do with certain currencies,
but it is good that I come and why am I here,
well, I have had experience and the
pleasant satisfaction of working with
javascript for a long time, having
started in web development since
2001.  So in July of this year I am
celebrating 20 years working with the
web development ecosystem, experiencing
many of the updates that
we know today thanks to the history
of everything behind how
technologies grew and a good part
of them.  Others were part of me,
obviously I did not get to know them, but
here I am still passionate and
in love with the use of everything that has to
do with content creation and
particularly also with teaching
within web development, so in
this case I am going to  tell a little about my
experience and what I do in all this
environment and well, over there you see baby
lopez my son oscar david barajas that we
also obviously hope one day
to take him to that next step and in the
development ecosystem so well let
's start a little with  these topics that
have to do with importance but
first I want to invite you to
tweet aso
es un gmx and use the hashtag y es com
because if you send some tweets right now
about how you are living it is sensational
and that eventuality we are having
of the  Life is how I am going to be posting
these tweets here too obviously
if you want teporaca I also want to see
there how you are living the experience
your questions or whatever you want to share you
can do at this point and here in
the integration we are going to do it to
tell a  secret of why I am
asking you this so well let's move on
with this then talk I have for
him
first of all let's talk a little about
javascript and well it is well known that
you see that it was created in the middle of the
battle of browsers yes a long time ago
time back when we obviously had
netscape navigator competing against
internet explorer and although at that
time there was a revolution and a
great battle to obviously gain
access to the internet through a
browser is where several
interesting technologies were born that
today obviously  we are using and
thanks to this we have javascript and
obviously here we also have several
points to consider and it is that it is known and it is
mentioned that it was created in
record time and obviously with some details
to consider and what
we can consider as loving  and hate
javascript but well let's not
worry right now about going into those
little details and things that obviously
are going to make us remember
issues that we don't like at all
about javascript but hey there is something that I do
want us to keep in mind and it is
concepts that  they are going to mortify us in
some way because we are not
completely used to understanding each other in
this way and if these little words are
elements that are going to have meaning
for you that are key to it because
today of byte so I want us to
understand this background  so that later
we can correctly understand the
tool and where obviously
things are going to change because it is going to be the
future and because this is going to change a lot
about how we are going to work correctly
within web development so I want us to
understand then concepts that
now as already  you can see as an
abbreviated 10 best js that will allow
us to have a system of modules
that is inspired by the 10 and that
obviously we have already used or
recognize some reserved words
like rich yesterday and export so
obviously here we have commons  and
now we are going to go into more detail about
things later we are going to have another of
the concepts that we are also going to
find in md and that I know causes
confusion because many are md that
has to do with amd processors here
and I will tell you  I mention it because obviously I have
received that question to look for, but what does it
have to do with here? Well, it is not
directly that, but more than anything, the
concept of five new
definition modes that will allow
us to have a division of what
was considered as in  Yes, I hope
to work with the synchrony part,
so we're just going to see and it
's currently widely used by Torrico yesterday 10, so
it's important to
also consider another of the points we're talking about
here. md or in this case universal module
definition is one in the  that
these concepts of like 10 md are also mixed
in order to have a way in which we
could work and all this before
obviously it is more click the standard
that regulates our
favorite programming language javascript will take out
or show what the script
module has been  which is obviously included in
this review is 2015 or better known
as 6 so from here is
where we already started to import
our resources and having various
elements such as the voice exporter are key
today and that can work
correctly with our browsers
so with our applications
once we understand these concepts
in this brief summary what I want is
that you keep them in mind and save them
for the essential part that will
allow us to understand the
particularities now that we have already talked
about this topic, then it has
Now the time has come for us to go into the
particularities of what I want us to
work on or understand in some way
with what has been byte, so it's
good that it's byte, many will ask, hey,
but what does it mean, what does it mean, how
it's made, because well  well let me
tell you that by is a tool
designed for the front end created by
evans young and well who are going to
look for text what is all this about too
baby telling more well well I tell you
that banjo is the creator of beauty is if
one of the  frameworks that also enters
into the water of the
frameworks war, which is how he also called it
where riad angular is, obviously it is
vélez and also view well, evans
you created this tool directly
to work with what is
view but not just for  This point
is also something important and interesting,
and that is that thanks to this developer
we have a powerful tool that
will allow us to create
JavaScript applications using a
framework, a resource that will
allow us to work without
any problem, be extremely fast.
since the word buy means fast in
French or comes from this context,
therefore we are talking about that we are going to be
able to be fast fast and it is one of the
things that this resource focuses on that
performance at that speed and that we are
not going to  to take advantage of us
as professionals, so something that
must be kept in mind and well, well, it is not
just designed for views, that must
be kept in mind that it is not anything more
exclusive to vio and that it will only be tied
there, let me tell you that  if it
is available so that you can
prepare your projects with the
main tools that we
use today such as frameworks and libraries
angular riad excel the same vanilla
javascript you can also work with
elements and resources within the script
as well as work with view probably
with tivo it is very  well integrated as
well as other tools such as project
olite element that obviously will
allow us to have a large
number of these
totally popular tools within the
factory development and be able to implement them
in this tool that will give
us the front-end  the
superpowers powers to create
applications much faster, much more
organized, but with some
characteristics that obviously will
denote changes in the way in which
we as professionals are going to
build our applications and
thus advance professionally having and
taking advantage of this tool as well  Let's
talk a little about these
characteristics and why I want us to
give a little power and weight to it,
and it is that these characteristics are
what makes us go towards the future and
go towards the tool that is going to
change the way in which  that we have been
working on and also the way in which
we are playing with the elements and that is that
here we are going to have some
main features such as
instant servers start which will
allow us an internal service
on demand through the mag screen
modules native and this is the
native keyword that is incorporated into
the resource and with this we are going to be
able to work much faster on the part
of our applications and it is also not going
to implement all the concepts that
have to do with our
favorite tools  to do
building, such as web payment,
others, so this is one of the things
that will also give us a great
advantage and I want to stop here at this
point and it is that many times when
we are working with our
applications or we are playing with some
element inside  of what we want to create
as professionals we have to have that
versatility of being able to work quickly to
test that the changes and that the
elements flow so that obviously
our time fully pays off
therefore that this feature is
present within this resource is going to be
essential  so that we don't have to put
large configurations and directly
start working with this
tool, another point that we
are also going to keep in mind is the whole
part of the placement module, which
will allow us to make these
elements extremely quickly with the
specific dependencies  that we are going to be
working, therefore
having all these resources without having
to wait for the server to
prepare our entire application and then
each change that we are
making is immediate and extremely
fast will mean that we do not
have to wait  some for each
compilation or in my example that I always
mention many times it usually happens that we
are making a kite a change
we make a type o and we see the change and we
see that it fails and we don't have to
go back and that takes time and we lose
time and this time obviously  It is
ultimately reflected in everything we
are doing as professionals,
therefore having an
optimized tool that will allow
us to be able to work without so much
problem is going to be key to this,
so here is a point that
personally  I quite liked another of
the elements that we are also going to
find are these functionalities that are going
to be incorporated now and that is that we remember
that as professionals we love to
mix technologies we love to work with
the trend with what is resorting
to today and good for that  In other words,
drive already incorporates elements that
have to do with tie script with css
with gis xxi, so it will allow
us to work correctly
with the great tools that we
are already incorporating or mix some
technologies such as these previously
mentioned, why take it out  benefit
your project and they are already obviously
incorporated within the core of this
tool so this is very
important to consider because it will
allow us to have projects with
the highest standards that we
are obviously wanting to implement within
our projects therefore it is  one
of the great characteristics and that
personally I have liked a lot and is
the acceptance that it has on taiz that
therefore it is something that must be put
a lot in its main point
another of the elements that I love
a lot in the optimized construction and
This means that it is going to work with the
part of itm a script modules to be able to
work correctly and also something
interesting is that it optimizes a lot
because it is working with concepts and
implementations that have already been
working in isolation from other
projects. This means that we can
implement resources  that are with roll
as well as with speed that will
allow us to optimize our
project much faster. One of the
great advantages is that we gain a lot of
performance in this area since there are
tools that are no longer fully
thought out within what  It is javascript
but we are using processes in
other programming languages ​​much
faster as it does and it is build
within the use of code therefore by
implementing these resources within
this tool we will be able to take
much more advantage of the preparation of
our  projects going from being able to
complete an extremely
robust application that reaches minutes
in its preparation to reducing it quite
drastically and this is something of the
characteristics that I personally
liked a lot I have been
experimenting and understanding a little more
since it is going  to get more out of it
when implementing all
our projects, so it's something that I
personally like a lot.
different frameworks and libraries
with which we can work we also
have a super community set and this is
something that personally I also
love a lot the community is always
important and thanks to the fact that there are
developers and that the community
supports itself we can have these tools and
plugins  that can be added
and that obviously will allow
us to get much more out of the
tool and this is something that I
always recommend and that I also ask you to
participate I ask you to explore and
obviously contribute to this great community and
not be anything else  consumers of the
tools that if they are going to give
you tools to obviously be able to
solve these problems in the
workplace, but obviously they
must also contribute and I invite you to
do so since it will be a great
satisfaction when you see that
part of  What you also
contributed is being used by a
large community, so thanks to this
element and to what we have as a
touring universe, we will be able to have
official elements within the documentation as
well as third-party elements
created like you or me that we want.
also contribute, so this is an
interesting point and well, we also have everything
that has to do with the apis written and
thought of in this great way, they are giving this
great resource that will allow
us to have what
the tools are today  that
the majority of the community is using
then and apis that are going to be
flexibly ready with a writing
on tie screen and that is going to allow us to be
able to integrate them and work with
our resources that are already
giving us byte within our
projects so these are  the
main characteristics that he highlighted
and that I obviously want to comment on, but
in particular there is one detail that I
want us to talk about, what problem does
it solve, what is the particular need
that we are going to have or why we
must keep in mind that this is key and
that it will allow us to  to us to be able to
take this advantage, well, I
want to mention that it comes to solve
something very particular and that is that
before he did not write
modes it was available for the part
of the browsers there was no way to
write javascript in a more
friendly and modular way  Therefore,
we resorted to these resources such as what
is web to jail among others that
helped us to modernize our application
in order to obviously have a
friendlier structure that is easier to
read to find the elements and that
allowed us to prepare our project
using the  building of our
applications, this
was obviously an essential part every time and
today many of the projects that we
create use these concepts and it's
good because we implement them
correctly since most of my
projects that I have worked on today  The
companies with which I have collaborated
use their account as their
favorite tool. This does not mean that it does not
work, simply that we already have a
detail since they have to work with
the search, the processing, the
concatenation of the modules and
obviously this will lead to the process that
it must have.  so that we have our
application as it should be, therefore
this has created a bottleneck in the
process of preparing our
projects, therefore this is where
resources such as what is
road look that is already implementing
these resources come to the fore  what for a bit of
context is not part of the project
desvele y es vélez a project that in
some way is also preparing us
so that we can implement
this natively ecma script modules
and that we can take it to that next
step therefore what  we wanted
to implement is that this is something
fundamental that is going to
give us much greater performance, much
more resources so that we can continue
advancing, therefore this problem is already
being worked on byte loco, they
began to implement it directly
within bio and today in  Today we have a
tool that, as he mentioned,
allows us not only to work with view
but also with practically any library frame
that we are using
today, as I mentioned
before, angular break view is a
welsch light element project, among others,
as well as configuring with tie
script and company javascript our
projects and this is very important that
we keep it in mind because it is what
gives it great value that it is not only
designed for a single tool but
is open to all of us to
implement these resources so
obviously at  Implementing the
module script natively will allow
us to work much better and
as you mentioned, it also happens with what we
are doing in
integrations with es view that will
allow us to work much faster with
processing our project since
it is working  with other languages ​​as we
can see that it's voice so that
's obviously a big big factor to
consider and give it
the opportunity to try it as
mentioned before there are technologies
that are still being supported and what you can
do so this is not
directly linked to only one, although it was born in
a very weak context since, as
evans mentioned, I, the creator,
leads this project to what
this tool has been, but it
is also open to the possibility that you can
create projects in the terminal with your client.
different technologies
that best suit your needs,
such as a project in riad in
angular javascript vanilla ice script
light element prieto as I
mentioned before so this is
something that I really liked, it is something
that I have been exploring because  I have
recently been starting to
work a little more with little m.
The whole concept that
it has also caught my attention, obviously as
some who know me will know, I am a
sleepless fan as well as develop in
my day to day since I collaborate with
projects that have  What to do with
technologies, so having a single
resource that would allow me to work with
them has been an essential part of being able to
reach this tool and with it
obviously start to get projects out of it I have already
started migrating some of my
projects to this resource because I
like it  the versatility that it gives me
and being able to work is quite a lot and if one of these
projects is what you are seeing here
this presentation that you can see that
it is here on this side as well as
this one and it says that it is bain well well they are
built with this point I have started  to
migrate some of my projects that
have to do with visual integration
as you can see at this point so
that they can start here although that
project has a bit of a mix of
various things like the dashboard in riad
has several tools to be revealed as well
as some  new ones that I am
starting to implement that are
built inside the king but
supported thanks to the technologies that
are delivering bits so that
makes me very, very happy about how to
obviously get a lot of weight out of this and well
I also want to invite you not to leave
out the  community there are many great
community many developers who
are participating and who
are obviously giving this resource the opportunity
yes I want to invite you to
enter the official community here I have
the link that is not so friendly but
take the screenshot obviously through
a  I'm going to pose a photo right now
so that you obviously do it like this and with
that you can remember the album and with this
you can access the community and be
aware of everything that is happening
in everything new that is coming and that
also as he mentioned to you  you can
collaborate it is very important that you give them
the opportunity
and many times you can start with the
translation part and later
solve some small box or
issues that will give you that
level of professional that you are
obviously I know how to look for it so  It is
also a point to consider and well
here quickly we are going to see here since
the community is throwing there
some tweets so we are going to put them
here quickly so that you
keep them fully in mind that we are
listening as this tool told you
that  You are seeing here that it
changed me, obviously these tweets
are also built directly with
this tool, so obviously I
am giving you a clear example
that you can implement it in almost
any project and integrate it into
tools such as this video
that we are creating  at this moment so
that you keep it fully in
mind and well to close I think that
in order to perhaps open up a little
questions and everything else I want to
talk a little about this subject of the
competition of verses and that is something
that  I want to reflect a bit because I don't
want you to stay with the idea of ​​ok, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, everyone, I'm leaving, I'm
changing, I'm leaving, don't give him
the opportunity,
he knew, he doesn't understand how it works,
what I told you about its main
characteristics that  It is implementing
modules as the level is faster
when starting a server and preparing your
project as the hot replacement mode
works that the
part of the features that
it incorporates with very standard resources of
tie script 10 ex ss incorporated
within  its choir as well as the
elements of its app and fully equipped with
this script well worth this
opportunity to know these
tools to adapt but this does not
mean that it comes to kill anyone who
comes to be better than anyone is not just
another tool and let's remember  que baile
is implementing concepts and resources
that have to do with es build
as well as incorporating role,
therefore it does not mean that tomorrow
is like they no longer use anything else this is
the main solution it is not an option
anymore and here  I'm also here to
reflect on tools. Get to know
explore and find out about new resources that
will help you to be a better
professional and this is what I want you to keep in
mind today you are
using bike yes and as I mentioned
I have several projects built with
many more tools but that
allow me to know and take
advantage of it when it is necessary and when you are going to
have that need when you are
obviously part of a team that has
big projects to solve big
needs of the business model if you
are going to be able to raise the  hand saying
hey you already know bye bye it allows
us and there you obviously explain this
talk and it will help you to
obviously have context of what is happening
and at what moment it happens to be able to take
advantage of what is at this moment do not
close yourself off saying  I am only pro angular I
am only pro royal I am only pro we are not
software engineers we are people who
know technology and we
take advantage of it to solve these
problems and obviously get paid
for it so I want to invite you to
never post or search for your verses
here I put it in code with some
tools but it is only the part
of know the tool and take it to that
next step it is the next point that
allows you to take advantage of it
so that is one of my reflections that I
always want you to  do and take it to
anyone to spell angular to ryan or it has
been like this python so anything that
has to do with our ecosystem don't
worry about looking for who is
more who is less who is the one who uses it
give the opportunity to the tools and
In this case, as I mentioned, I have been
migrating several of my projects that
allow me to take advantage of it, being able to
prepare it is much faster, being
able to make immediate deployments, being able to
use a friendly
and easy work environment and good, as I mentioned
initially, I am an educator.  that
allows me or I have to have
some environments ready practically to
be doing my projects and to be
able to be working and teaching
other people well, today he
has taken that to start teaching I
have been recording some
recently and with them I was
beginning to  evangelize now with this
tool and if using it with my
first favorite bookstores such as
bell times as well as now so that I
can mention this point to you and well I have nothing left to do but
thank you obviously for your
status for perhaps you have just passed in
time for questions  my name is oscar
baraja he is better known as gene x
this was my experience working with
this tool and the advantages that i have
seen in particular you can
find me on social networks like gnx and you
can also see my content or my
blog in general x point of o  If you are already
in the crypto world, here is the url
that you can also find in this
ecosystem, although we remember that this
relay does not work in all
browsers, so